les élections de mi-mandat ont lieu
entre deux élections présidentielles
comme toutes les élections fédérales
elles ont lieu le mardi suivant le
premier lundi de novembre tous les deux
ans elles permettent de remettre en jeu
l'ensemble des 435 sièges de la chambre
des représentants et un peu plus du
tiers des 100 sièges du sénat
au coeur de ce scrutin c'est le contrôle
du bras législatif du gouvernement
américain les élections de mi mandat
constitue souvent un référendum sur les
politiques mises en place par le parti
au pouvoir et le président en exercice
si le président pères au moins l'une des
deux chambres
et ce fut le cas depuis les 20 dernières
années cela peut nuire à l'adoption de
ces politiques pour les deux années qui
lui restent à la tête des états unis
parallèlement à ces élections fédérales
ce sera aussi l'occasion de faire élire
36 des 50 gouverneurs d'état mais aussi
de combler toute une série d'autres
postes en jeu dans des administrations
locales
certains électeurs auront aussi à se
prononcer lors de référendums
d'initiative populaire sur des sujets
qui sont aussi divers que le cannabis et
des hausses de taxes